a great day of fun had on the golf  course will make a world of difference  for families with children who have rare  diseases  almost 130 golfers Hit The Greens at the  Painted Desert Golf Club recently for  the second annual Tia for rare golf  tournament all proceeds benefit the  Little Miss Hannah foundation and the  turnout was incredible the community  helped raise more than thirty thousand  dollars for the foundation  not thirty thousand dollars will fund  anywhere from 40 to 50 pieces of medical  and therapy equipment which is the main  focus of our foundation and we could not  be more proud of that hearing from the  executive director Jenny kershel there  those pieces of medical and therapy  equipment they're typically not covered  by medical insurance families in  southern Nevada will receive the items  over the next few months